president biden's saying his american
recovery proposal will help the
economic recovery from the cobit
pandemic and today he announced the very
first part of the plan
he says focusing on infrastructure and
would add millions of jobs
washington correspondent alexandra limon
breaks it down
and that job creation is why the
president is calling this infrastructure
package the american jobs plan
saying it will create millions of new
jobs for example in the clean energy and
construction sectors
president joe biden wants to invest 2.3
trillion dollars in america's
infrastructure
with about a quarter of the money going
toward repairing
transit systems so once in a generation
investment
in america unlike anything we've seen or
done
since we built the interstate highway
system and the space race decades ago
the plan will also invest hundreds of
billions to make
water systems safer expand broadband
access and increase
affordable housing the president is also
calling for significant investments in
clean energy
dedicating 100 billion dollars to
modernizing the nation's power grid and
making it more resilient to climate
disasters
and the plan invests in charging
stations to help shift the nation to
electric cars
senator chuck schumer says all of that
will create millions of new jobs
every community large and small rural
suburban
and urban will benefit from this robust
american jobs plan washington democrats
have lost their mind but the biggest
challenge for president biden will be
getting republicans like missouri
congressman jason smith on board with
the price tag
after the government already spent
trillions on pandemic relief bills
just within the last year that comes to
a total combined spending of 10 trillion
dollars
and all of it's being paid for by the
largest tax increase in the history of
the united states
the president's proposed tax increases
will actually undo
some of the tax cuts to corporations and
the richest americans that were approved
by the republican congress
in 2017. reporting in washington
alexandra limon